today we've got something exciting lined
up for you we know that not everyone is
a coding Wizard and guess what that's
perfectly okay in the ever evolving
world of I.T there are plenty of
opportunities that don't require you to
be a coding Prodigy so if you are ready
to explore the top 10 IT jobs that don't
require coding skills in 2024 you're in
the right place let's Dive Right In
number 10 IT project manager kicking off
our list at number 10 is the role of an
I.T project manager this job is all
about coordination planning and making
sure that it projects run smoothly no
coding required but excellent
organizational and communication skills
are a must
you'll be the captain of the ship
steering the project to success
as an I.T project manager you'll find
yourself overseeing teams budgets and
timelines your ability to juggle
multiple tasks and keep everyone on the
same page will be your greatest asset in
this role your primary focus will be on
delivering projects within scope on time
and within budget
number nine it support specialist
next up at number nine we have the it
support specialist if you're the go-to
person in your family or a circle of
friends for Tech troubleshooting this
might be your calling I.T support
Specialists help users with their Tech
related issues ensuring that everything
runs smoothly it's like being the hero
of the IT world without the need for
coding as an I.T support specialist
you'll need strong problem solving
skills and the ability to explain
technical issues in a way that's easy
for non-techies to understand
you'll be the first point of contact for
anyone experiencing it problems so
patience and empathy are also crucial
number eight business analyst coming in
at number eight we've got business
analysts these professionals bridge the
gap between I.T and business they gather
and analyze data to help organizations
make informed decisions it's a role that
requires problem solving skills
communication and a deep understanding
of both Tech and business but not coding
expertise
business analysts are like the
detectives of the I.T World they
investigate processes identify
inefficiencies and recommend solutions
to improve business operations your
ability to analyze data and communicate
your findings effectively will be your
key strengths in this role number seven
cyber security analyst in the seventh
spot we have cyber security analysts
with the increasing importance of online
security this field is booming cyber
security analysts work diligently to
protect organizations from cyber threats
while you'll need to understand security
protocols you won't have to write a line
of code to keep the digital world safe
cyber security is all about staying one
step ahead of hackers and other cyber
threats in this role you'll be
responsible for monitoring networks
identifying vulnerabilities and
implementing security measures to
safeguard sensitive data it's a high
stakes job that doesn't require coding
but Demands a keen eye for detail
number six data analysts moving on to
number six we find data analysts these
professionals play a crucial role in
turning raw data into valuable insights
you'll need to work with data tools and
software but coding skills are not a
prerequisite if you enjoy unraveling the
Mysteries hidden within data this might
be your dream job
data analysts are like data detectives
they collect clean and analyze data to
help organizations make data-driven
decisions your ability to spot Trends
create visualizations and communicate
your findings will be your superpowers
in this role
number five user experience ux designer
and number five we have user experience
designers they focus on creating
user-friendly interfaces and ensuring
that websites and apps are a joy to use
while design skills are essential you
don't need to be a coder to craft
outstanding user experiences
ux designers put themselves in the shoes
of users to create intuitive and
enjoyable digital experiences
you'll be responsible for wireframing
prototyping and conducting user research
your goal is to make technology
accessible and delightful for everyone
without writing a single line of code
number four it sales coming in at the
fourth spot we've got it sales Yes you
heard that right selling it products and
services can be a highly rewarding
career your job will be to understand
your clients needs and match them with
the right Tech Solutions coding nope not
needed it sales professionals are the
bridge between tech companies and their
customers your ability to understand
complex Tech Solutions and translate
them into benefits for clients will be
your strengths building relationships
negotiating contracts and staying up to
date with tech Trends will be crucial in
this role
number three technical writer now let's
talk about number three on our list
technical writers hey that's me
technical writers like myself create
documentation manuals and guides to make
Tech understandable to everyone we
bridge the gap between the tech world
and those who need to use it all without
coding
as a technical writer you'll be
responsible for translating technical
jargon into plain language your
documentation will help users
troubleshoot issues understand software
features and follow best practices
Clarity attention to detail and a knack
for simplifying complex topics are your
tools of the trade
number two it trainer in the runner-up
position at number two we have it
trainers these professionals educate
others on how to use various software
systems or applications effectively
teaching Tech is a rewarding career and
it doesn't require you to be a coding
Guru
it trainers are like Tech Educators
you'll create training materials conduct
workshops and help users become
proficient with the software they need
your ability to explain Concepts in a
clear and engaging manner will be your
superpower
number one network administrator drum
roll please taking the top spot at
number one on our list of IT jobs that
don't require coding skills in 2024 is
the network administrator these unsung
heroes keep the digital highways running
smoothly they manage networks
troubleshoot issues and ensure that data
flows seamlessly while networking
knowledge is crucial you won't be
writing complex code Network
administrators are the backbone of it
infrastructure you'll configure maintain
and troubleshoot network devices to
ensure reliable connectivity your skills
in network management security and
problem solving will be your keys to
success
and there you have it our top 10 IT jobs
that don't require coding skills in 2024
expanded to provide you with more
insights and information
remember the IT world is vast and
there's a place for everyone even if
you're not a coding wizard
so if you're passionate about technology
explore these exciting career options
thanks for tuning in and don't forget to
like subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to stay updated with all things
Tech on our Channel until next time stay
curious and keep exploring the worlds of
I.T
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you